where I discovered you was my so-called
life and that is so weird you audition
for this thing and it's between you and
Alicia Silverstone who went on to
clueless Fame and all that stuff you
nail it you're the second person to
audition and they say you are the person
right this is going to be your role and
you get the role and I think that was
such a great show so brilliant but all
the networks sort of passed on it right
they wouldn't air it well yeah the pilot
didn't get picked up initially so I went
to high school
um and then halfway through uh my
freshman year it did get picked up so
then we all my parents and I went my
brother was in college at this point but
you pack your bags and move to L.A move
to L.A it was such a good show I can't
believe networks passed on that for so
long I mean aren't you a little shocked
by that no I think it was like it
doesn't matter who did it first it
matters who did it second kind of thing
I think it was just so fresh it was so
Innovative
um and I I think that people did you
know it was kind of provocative for that
reason and that's not always very
appealing to networks but yeah we didn't
even do a full season we did 19 out of
22 Episodes but then it got picked up by
various cable stations and then had this
incredible afterlife and
um did you like doing it I loved it it
was so wonderful
um everybody involved was just so gifted
and you know it was it was a great
experience